Carson, who was at the
Capitol that day, as you know,
was your vice president, Mike Pence,
who says that you endangered his life
on that day.
I don't think he was in any danger.
Mr.
President,
do you feel that you owe him an apology?
No, because he did something wrong.
He should have put the votes back
to the state legislatures.
And I think we would have
had a different outcome. I really do.
And he doesn't have the authority
to do that. As you know what,
the vice president does
not have the authority to reject
this election,
not just now, because it's interesting.
Let's keep it interesting. Right.
I like Mike Pence very much.
He's a very fine man.
He's a very nice man.
He made a mistake.
His lawyer said you cannot move.
I call them the human conveyor belt.
I said,
even if the votes you mean
talk to us, like
even if the votes
are absolutely fraudulent, he can't.
Yes, sir.
He can't even read.
And the Democrats played it
and the rhinos played it.
And then the election was over.
They told him he couldn't do it.
And Mike said to me, I can't do it.
The lawyers told me, you can't do it.
They can't do it.
But the lawyers are wrong.
Because right after the election,
they all met the rhinos
and the Democrats,
and they worked out a plan
to make sure that future
vice presidents
don't do what I said you could do.
That's not what happened.
You're referring to the electoral count.
I've read I've read that there is
there is no authority.
Legal experts,
including Republican legal experts,
say that he does not
have that authority, persuasion.
But why did they change the law then,
saying that you can't do it?
They didn't change the law.
They strengthened the law
because they were worried about
the strength it you could do
It's not what it means.
Thank you.
They strengthened my card,
the right to do it.
They convinced him he didn't.
And it was a horrible thing.
For our country.
If you would have sent those votes
back to Georgia, Pennsylvania
and other states, Wisconsin,
which if you look at Wisconsin,
they've virtually admitted
now that the election was rigged.
If they would have sent those votes back
to many of those states,
they would not come back
in the affirmative.
And remember what I said
and you just said it pretty much.
You admitted what I said was right.
They said he didn't have
the right to do it
and he did have the right to do it.
And that's why they changed the law
taking that right away.
I should note that your campaign paid
for a recount that happened in Wisconsin.
It actually had more votes
for President Biden by the end of it.